CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman
joins us at the table Ricky good morning
good morning everybody who looks at
those pictures it just makes your blood
boil it's hard to believe this is
happening in the United States of
America how is it possible that it's
okay to separate these young kids from
their their parents all under the guise
of we're just enforcing the law is there
a law on the books no there is no law on
the books there was a settlement of a
case back in 1997 the Flores case that
somehow gives this administration the
ability to say that they will have a
zero-tolerance policy but when the
Attorney General and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders go and say the use the Bible as
an analogy and say that thou shalt obey
the law that the law is really not there
it is purely policy and it can be change
change the legislation has to come from
and that's why pallas exchange was so
important there in the briefing room to
the White House press Secretary's this
is about policy there is no doubt paula
was correct and asking that question in
the way that you did because when you
are dealing with policy it is a far cry
from having some black leather law there
was a court decision and ultimately it
can be dealt with within the Congress
this is not something that has to remain
should we talk about now the New York
State is suing the Trump charity
alleging broad misconduct some of which
was first reported in the Washington
Post what will happen with this well
this is a very serious lawsuit and this
lawsuit has merit on a number of levels
including referrals to the IRS and
referrals to the Federal Election
Commission what happened there saying
that the Trump administration when
Donald Trump had this charity so you
have to look back not the president but
back when he's in the campaign when he
had this charity since 1987 that it
basically again followed no law that
there are laws written that say how a
charity must be run there was no
oversight so what did he use with
Garrity for benefit personal benefit
paying off legal obligations which you
cannot do and ultimately also
used for the campaign in Iowa to have
payouts about the veterans organizations
just before the Iowa caucus all right
Ricky clear man thanks